brian those record numbers are really
concerning everyone and today on a call
with state health officials
the governor realizes we've not seen a
significant downward trend
this comes after announcing state home
2.0 to encourage nevadans to try and
stay home for the next couple of weeks
the question that everybody wants to
know now is could we face another
shutdown
kate houston asked the governor for an
answer
it's a difficult situation trying to
protect our economy and the job we're
doing everything we can i'm encouraging
all of our locals to practice the best
protocols that we possibly can
at the same time i don't want to shut
down the entire economy if i can at all
avoid it governor steve sisselak says
he's walking a tight rope of protecting
the economy
and protecting public health he joined a
call with members of nevada health
response who say current strategies are
not minimizing the spread of the virus
over the past week the governor and his
team have gathered information and input
from different stakeholders
governor sissel act says many factors
are being considered
to see what steps need to be taken
moving forward to be blunt
our state is surging and continues to
surge i'm incredibly concerned about the
severity of coca-19 in our state my
administration is currently exploring
all mitigation
options available to get this under
control nevada health response says it's
important to remember that cases
reported today were potentially exposed
to the virus a week ago or longer
so the state should start seeing trends
decline as data comes in during the
stay-at-home 2.0 period
there's a light at the end of this
tunnel as far as i'm concerned and i'm
hopeful that we can just continue to
push through this and press forward
as the vaccine becomes available we can
attempt to vaccinate as many of our
residents as we possibly can and things
will start
improving as we head into next year
governor siselak says restrictions and
guidelines will only work if people
follow them
kate houston 8 news now the governor
says he plans to provide an update on
the status of kovat 19
as well as any steps being taken but he
didn't provide an exact date on when
that might be